because it's a training camp in
pre-season unlike any other it's going
to introduce a whole new universe of
potentially crazy stories enter the
seattle seahawks shireen rookie
cornerback kamal siverand was cut
after he was caught on video
trying to sneak a female visitor into
the team hotel and he put her in
seahawks gear so
the video cameras would or whoever was
monitoring them would believe that she
was actually member of the team
uh it didn't work he was abruptly
released now look this is the sliding
scale and and you know the first example
that i remember this came from jimmy
johnson where there was somebody who
fell asleep in a team meeting and he cut
the guy and they asked and and what if
torah and what was the response what if
troy aikman had fallen asleep in a team
meeting you remember
yeah
exactly it wouldn't have happened yeah
yeah i would have gotten him a pillow
that would and so so yeah if it was
russell wilson trying to sneak ciara in
uh pete carroll would have helped with
her bags but but the reality is when you
are one of the lower men on the roster
and you do something this ridiculously
stupid
that's what happens and amy trask our
good friend uh former raiders president
chimed in if she would have dressed as
marshawn lynch and stood on a marker
that said one yard line they would have
ignored her i mean that is an all-time
mic drop from amy trask and uh look hey
look it's it's funny it's crazy it's
entertaining but at the same time
shireen it's horrifying to me because
if one guy is going to do something
that's stupid that clearly is against
what they're trying to get guys to do
and not do
to keep the virus out of the team what
are these guys going to do when they go
home at night what are they can if if
one guy is going to do something that
over the top there's going to be other
guys there's too many players in the
league there's too many coaches in the
league there's too many staff that are
in that tier 1 and tier 2 group
somebody's going to do something stupid
and bring that virus into a team and
then you've got the foundation laid for
an outbreak
yeah well the first thing is clarence
hill our good friend from the fort worth
star telegram called me yesterday and he
said
is this guy aggie or is this guy
oklahoma state cowboy because
he went to a m as a freshman which i had
forgotten and then ended up at oklahoma
state so of course i said it's oklahoma
state cowboy so i'm going to put it on
yeah i i do think that you know this
just presents a problem for nfl teams
and and how are they going to keep this
virus under control if guys are going to
do things
like this during a pandemic and and we
saw it with one guy who's probably not
going to get another chance in the nfl
he better hope the xfl starts up and
maybe he gets a chance over there
because he's he's not going to get
signed by anybody after pulling this
stunt
that he tried to pull and so you know it
does make you wonder what else are guys
going to do and they have to do the
right things and obviously not everybody
is going to do the right thing because
we've already seen it
well and and the the reality is that
double standard that
uh jimmy jones once applied jimmy jimmy
jimmy johnson once applied jimmy johnson
once applied in the meeting room is
going to apply to the rest of the roster
and if if somebody does something stupid
who is a key player they're not going to
cut him but you know that i
at a time when the message that keeps
coming from the league office from the
teams is you know we're very confident
everybody gets it everybody's doing the
right things or he's taking it seriously
this so dramatically cuts against it
that that it just horrifies me about
what the possibilities really are and
and as they get closer and closer and
we're just three weeks away from the
moment where you cut the rosters from 80
down to 53. this year it's 80 not 90.
everybody's got to be at 80 as of now
because of of managing managing the the
realities of the pandemic once you go
from 80 to 53
and you have you're down to you know
those last couple guys and you're trying
to figure out who gets the roster spot
how much do you factor into it your
projection based upon what you know of
the guy as to whether or not he's truly
someone you can trust to not do
something stupid
what happened with the seahawks
underscores the importance for those
last few roster spots is this someone
that we know will do what needs to be
done or is this someone that we think
there's a chance he's going to do
something stupid reckless and selfish
and potentially bring the virus into the
facility
well and how much does it play into
whether the guys had coveted or not if
he's had covet has the antibodies maybe
that plays into a decision too yeah
we're going to take this guy who's
already had it who we know is going to
be there and is not going to bring it in
because he's already had and we don't
know how long the antibodies last i
understand all that but i do think it's
going to factor in in some of these
decisions with their decision making and
whether they've had the virus or not
when it comes down to those last few
roster spots they want guys who are
available they want guys who are going
to do the right things and that's more
important this year than it's ever been
in the nfl
you touched on something that i don't
think we've discussed recently the idea
that if you've already had it you do
have some degree of attractiveness to
the team because they don't have to
worry about you getting it if you've
already had it now we still don't know
enough about what it means to have the
antibodies how long it makes you immune
from getting covet 19 again but when
peter king reported earlier this week
that there were six teams that had no
positive tests during the first few
weeks of camp i had an executive with
the team reach out to me and say i think
the reason is
you got people who have already had it
that that's one of the reasons why
there's been no positives with those
teams and you know some teams have had
the experience when they do the antibody
test and they don't announce that that
isn't that isn't front and center
there's no list of of players who have
been tested as having the antibodies and
we know they're good to go at least for
now
you know guys who spent the offseason in
texas and florida a lot of those guys
are coming in and they've got the
antibodies which means they've had it
and when anthony lynn on hard knocks the
other night the chargers coach came
right out of the gates and said hey i
was infected you just wonder how many
guys have been that they knew about it
and didn't say anything
or they didn't know about until they got
the antibody test but but that's a real
factor as well when you get down to
those last few spots shireen is is this
someone who's had it even if we don't
know how long it's going to last we
don't have to worry about this guy being
all of a sudden unavailable to us over
the first couple of months of the season
these these are these are you know
should it be a factor should not be a
factor it doesn't matter it is this is
the kind of stuff football coaches are
going to be thinking about in order to
craft their team
yeah the the
you know i don't know who first said it
i know jimmy johnson used it a lot and
tony dungy you have to be available to
your team that's the most important
thing availability and
and they know those guys are going to be
there when it counts if they've already
had covet that they're not going to get
it again or they don't think they'll get
it again so that's the the most
important thing i think that when it
comes down to those last few roster
spots we're going to see now we've also
seen some teams might go to these many
bubbles with the saints and the cowboys
or some teams going to carry that over
to the regular season and they can't
make them do it but they can make it
voluntary and the leaders of the team
could put pressure the dak prescotts and
ezekiel elliott's right could put
pressure uh on those other players to
say hey we're going to do this we're
going to stay in this hotel we're not
going to go out and we're going to have
room service and we're going to do all
the right things during the season so
that'll be interesting to watch too
whether we see some teams go to their
own midi bubble
in their home city
some teams may do it tuesday to sunday
as well not that that completely
eliminates the risk but if if you know
ideally in theory if something happens
while the player's at home sunday monday
you you you get the positive early
enough that you know what's going on and
you otherwise have everyone else on
lockdown from tuesday to sunday but yeah
that's going to be one of the keys to
keeping the virus out having the many
bubbles getting the veterans to buy in
and then getting the rookies to just
follow along and that may be a factor in
crafting the final roster which guys are
more likely to volunteer to stay in a
hotel for the full season which guys are
more likely to resist and you know young
guys in their early 20s
they're not nearly as equipped as you
know fully grown adults to keep their
their
their beliefs and their opinions and
their habits and their attitudes
discreet i think that good coaches and
evaluators are going to know who to
who to who to trust and who not to trust
and those are all going to be factors
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports